holy [ __ ] Ninja Assassin which is
directed by James McTeague the guy who
directed V for Vendetta I only say this
because apparently in the TV spots he's
known as the creators of the Matrix
trilogy they sent that for V for
Vendetta and I said that for Ninja
Assassin both directed by James McTeague
saying the creators of the Matrix
trilogy absolutely implies this directed
by the Wachowski brothers okay so what
schooler directed by the guy who
directed V for Vendetta or the guys who
directed the matrix and then three other
[ __ ] movies I mean give this guy credit
don't put him in the shadows of the guys
who directed Speed Racer okay onto Ninja
Assassin the plot of Ninja Assassin is
pretty simple it bounces back and forth
all Tarantino style between the present
day and the past childhood training of
our main character ninja badass as we
saw in the trailer he ultimately tells
his clan Daniel I want a fight - not now
not ever
let's go and now they've been hunting
him and he's been hunting them ever
since
and we have two investigators looking
into the possibility of these secret
ninja clans but no April O'Neil and they
kind of do remind me of the
investigators from V for Vendetta they
provide outside eyes looking into the
whole situation for us but you don't
come to see them we came to see the oh
my god I can't believe that just
happened crazy ninja badassness yeah I
said badassness that's a word and yes
the badassness is ridiculous in this
movie to make the ninjas almost like
supernatural which [ __ ] there are
zillions of ninja movies out there in
which we see realistic looking ninjas I
enjoyed seeing mildly supernatural
ninjas we're talking like they disappear
in one place and end up in another place
you know kind of like
no camera tricks here ladies and
gentlemen that was real ish now the
special effect specifically the blood
and they're they're a little blade one
which wouldn't matter if you had less
than 36,000 gallons of it splashed all
over the screen it had a lot of blood
ultimately the movie felt like ninja
gaiden the movie that's ultimately what
it was ninja gaiden the movie but a
little more ridiculous so the plot was a
little light you really don't care much
about the characters it was a lot of fun
and you want the main character to take
out hi Hachi Mishima and the karate kids
which is all you can really ask for
that's all you really should ask for
going into the movie if you ask for any
more than that you might have forgotten
that it has a title that's no deeper
than Ninja Assassin if for nothing else
this movie should do just fine to watch
that new moon after taste out of your
mouth so check it out it's a bloody good
time just in time for turkey day